all right welcome
so my name is Philip and this is a
session about what I think is one of the
most fascinating topics in all of
technology and that is of course Quantum
Computing so first of all thank you all
for coming I really appreciate you
coming I really do
uh because this is sort of a a niche
Topic in many aspects especially as you
know Quantum Computing is not really
that particularly useful for anything at
this stage yet so from that perspective
I was
I was not expecting that people would
show up I was actually worried that
nobody will show up and you know we are
not going to learn anything particularly
useful because of that as well however I
hope that I hope that this session this
next hour will sort of give you a little
bit of a glimpse into the future in
terms of how our computational models
might look like going forward and I hope
that this session will also encourage
you to dive deeper into this fascinating
field you know Quantum Computing sits at
the intersection I'm gonna move the
Mouse sits at the intersection of
physics computer science mathematics a
little bit of chemistry maybe even
philosophy as we will learn in this
session so there is something there for
everybody and so if you'd like to dive
deeper after the session and I also have
a book recommendation for you so this is
a sort of a companion book to the
session the book that I wrote last year
and it takes you all the way from the
basics of quantum mechanics to writing
Quantum algorithms
and this is the company that I work for
and I'm actually based in Switzerland
so let's begin by having a look at the
bigger picture okay now it might seem
like Quantum Computing is actually uh
some sort of a latest craze or latest
fashion trend out of Silicon Valley
but that couldn't be further from the
truth in fact Quantum Computing is a
scientific field dates back to the early
80s when Richard Feynman famously
suggested that in order for us to be
able to simulate nature to simulate the
processes going on in nature the
Dynamics of natural processes we should
be building computational models that
are quantum mechanical at their core
rather than be binary and this is
effectively the definition of a quantum
computer it is a device that is
performing its calculations or its
computations using the principles of
quantum information Theory and
throughout the session we shall sort of
unpack what this really means
for now we could say that the
consequence of this is that quantum
computers can actually hardness the
power of the quantum effect and those
are really weird and really strange and
really bizarre if we consider them from
our everyday macroscopic perspective so
first of all there is the superposition
so a Quantum object can actually be in
many different states at the same time
and this of course doesn't seem to make
much sense but that is a consequence of
the mathematical formalism of quantum
mechanics then we have entanglement
Quantum objects can actually become
entangled with each other and once they
do they can exhibit correlations that
are impossible for us to reproduce in
our everyday macroscopic world
then we have wave particle duality so
Quantum objects can actually behave like
a wave so be sort of spread out
spatially or they can behave like
point-like objects depending on how we
choose to interact with them
and finally there is Randomness this
uncertainty that is built into the very
fabric of our reality
and all of those things we shall explore
in one way or the other throughout the
session but before we get there a very
brief historical Outlook
or historical View
in 1985 David Deutsche who despite his
last name is not German but actually
British it's a brilliant physicist from
the University of Oxford he developed
the first Universal model for Quantum
computation
and to this day this is really you know
from the mathematical perspective this
is how we think about Quantum computing
then in 1994 Peter Shore of IBM
developed what is still today one of the
most amazing algorithms that we have for
quantum computers this is the integer
factorization algorithm now it doesn't
seem like anything particularly exciting
but it achieves exponential speed up
over the best known classical
alternative
which means that for certain types of
problems quantum computer sufficiently
large quantum computer would be able to
solve them probably in a matter of
minutes maybe hours and a classical
computer would require Millions if not
billions of computational years
and we also know that given a
sufficiently large quantum computer and
sufficiently stable the the algorithm
that Peter Shore developed can be used
to break most of our currently used
public-private cryptography schemes such
as RSA or elliptic curves
and of course this is quite a big deal
because that is effectively what
underpins the security on the internet
today
then in 1998
the first quantum computer was built it
was a tiny machine consisting of two
Quantum bits it was using a technology
called nuclear magnetic resonance and
interestingly enough this is the same
core technology that is used in MRI
scanners so the next time you are at the
hospital and you see an MRI scanner you
can sort of think of it as a cousin of a
quantum computer
then in 2016 IBM launched the first
Cloud platform for quantum computers and
this was a big deal because it's sort of
democratized quantum computers right
like you no longer have to be a postdoc
or a researcher at a really good
University with a really good Quantum
program but you can actually access
quantum computers uh as we would say
from the comfort of your own keyboard
and now other providers like Amazon with
a bracket service or Microsoft with
Azure Quantum offer the same type of
access to Quantum Hardware through their
Cloud platforms
now the way you can think of quantum
computers and I mean this is a very
crude picture so we should not spend too
much time on it but just to provide a
little bit of structure you can sort of
think of quantum computers a sort of
co-processors to your regular program to
your regular
CPU that simply sit in the cloud right
and so on this picture the blue line
here this is the what we will say
classical Computing so when we speak
about regular conventional compute
computations from the quantum
perspective we would often call them
classical so
at the the most crude in a most crude
form we can break down the program into
input then the workflow execution and
the output and as your program executes
at some point it might decide you know
what this particular task or this
particular routine is actually suited
for a quantum computer which means you
would call an orchestrator that sits in
the cloud that is able to take your
input and convert it into the state that
can be fed into a quantum computer and
that state then evolves according to the
laws of quantum mechanics and we shall
see what this means and ultimately we
need to extract classical beats so zeros
and ones out of the quantum computer and
this happens through the process called
measurement and those bits can then flow
back to your original program again the
information density in the slide is
probably quite low but at least it
provides a little bit of a structure so
we shall dive deeper of course as we
progress with the session but before we
get there I wanted to also offer a few
words of warning because there's a lot
of quantum hype in the media
so first of all we currently find
ourselves in an era that is called noisy
intermediate scale Quantum Computing
which is a very fancy way of saying that
quantum computers make a lot of Errors
at the moment and they are not really
useful for much right
the second thing is that even though we
speak about quantum computers we really
only have Quantum processing units there
is no Quantum Storage and there is no
Quantum memory at this I mean there's a
lot of research in that space but
there's nothing that is integrated
together with the processing unit so
effectively we just have Quantum
processing units they are very limited
in terms of their input and very limited
in terms of their output they can do
interesting things when the program
executes but that's about it so that is
that is worth mentioning and finally
even if we have in the future much
bigger and much more stable quantum
computers which is what we expect we
will have at least
we think that they will never really
become general purpose computational
devices they would be
extremely useful for some specialized
use cases
and in those cases they might actually
revolutionize the the specific field but
but I think you know regular silicon
based computation will not go away
so what are the use cases where we think
quantum computers will be useful I mean
it goes back to the original suggestion
from Feynman pretty much anything that
is at its core a quantum mechanical
problem especially chemistry right
molecular simulations drug discoveries
Material Science
all those things can actually be mapped
quite easily to the Dynamics that go on
in quantum computer so those are the
types of problems that we think will be
able to to solve I mean
in general you could imagine a situation
where
um just about any chemical reaction
could be simulated on a quantum computer
without actually using any chemicals and
that would be tremendous
then climate and Energy Research again
this is stuff that at its core is
quantum mechanical so we think we will
be able to map those problems quite well
now going outside of the realm of
quantum Computing and more into the
space of quantum Communications we know
that Quantum Communications can provide
us with security that is actually
underpinned by the laws of nature so
effectively unbreakable security so
there's a lot of research in terms of
building for example Quantum Internet
then machine learning is a is an active
area of research so people are trying to
combine machine learning or more broadly
AI with Quantum computations however the
major hurdle is of course the the input
and the output limitations for quantum
computers because they are really not
that suited for the so-called big data
problem
and and finally optimization so all
kinds of optimization problems where you
know
um the different paths to the solution
have to be explored you know especially
in logistics maybe also in financial
simulations we think that quantum
computers will be very good at that
now for the purpose of this session we
are going to be using Q sharp for the
examples and also Azure quantum
so I wanted to spend a few moments um
talking about this just to make sure
that everybody's on the same page now
all the theory that we shall cover is
actually independent of Q sharp and
other Quantum and it's equally
applicable to other uh tech stocks
so Microsoft has this Quantum
development kit which allows you to
build Quantum programs either using Q
sharp which is a dedicated Quantum
programming language or python which is
usually the language that's preferred by
the Academia
if you have a document development
background you you would feel somewhat
at home with Q sharp I think because the
tool chain is quite similar I mean the
development happens in vs on vs code you
would be building your program using.net
CLI you would be
you'd be using packages from from nougat
so actually qsr packages are hosted on
nougat and so on
it is of course not a.net language
because there is no.net for Quantum
Hardware but the tool chain is somewhat
similar
then a Quantum development kit is
actually a family of Library so it's not
just the core Quantum library but also
libraries that can help you get started
in in different types of fields to which
Quantum Computing might be applied and
finally you can build sort of Standalone
applications you can think of them as a
quasi uh Quantum console applications or
you can actually use Jupiter Jupiter
notebooks for more interactive
experience and you can up to a certain
size of a program you can simulate it
locally and of course you can also
submit it to Azure Quantum and Azure
Quantum is a is a Quantum platform that
supports Q sharp programs it also
supports programs that are built with
kiss kit or Circ and those are two of
the most popular Quantum Computing
Frameworks for python
then in Azure Quantum of course you get
access to real Quantum Hardware now
interestingly enough there is no first
party Hardware from Microsoft so
Microsoft is building their own quantum
computer this has been announced but
they have actually chosen the
technological part that is much
different from all the other vendors and
because of that they are actually on a
completely different timeline and there
will probably not be a quantum computer
from Microsoft for for quite a few years
still
there are three providers currently that
Supply Hardware to Azure Quantum one is
called ionq the other is called
Continuum and the third one is called
rigati so these are all startups in that
space
now we also have access to simulators in
in the cloud so those are vendor
specific simulators so they can be a bit
more accurate than the simulators that
are locally in the quantum development
kit so and finally you get free credits
per provider you get actually 500 per
provider to spend and try out stuff and
the typical in interaction path with
Azure Quantum would be to use azcli
which is the command line tool to to
manage your Azure subscription
and and for that there is an official
Quantum extension that can be installed
and the fact that you can submit your
program as a so-called job for execution
and once your program is submitted it
gets typically placed in a queue because
as you can imagine the quantum Hardware
resources are really scarce so you have
to wait in a queue unless you pay a lot
of a lot of money to to Azure then you
can bypass the queue and ultimately you
can fetch the output of your program
once once it it it executes and the
output might look like this and if it
doesn't make much sense then should not
worry because we are going to have a
look at this in a moment and from the
more architectural standpoint the way
this works is that there is
um another quantum workspace that you
have to create for yourself in your
Azure subscription and behind it there
is a storage so you you also have a
storage account and effectively your
program gets uploaded to the storage and
from there it gets queued for execution
on a specific provider which could be a
simulator or it could be a real Quantum
hardware and ultimately once your
program completes then the result is
written back to the storage and it can
be fetched from there and and all this
orchestration is done by by the quantum
extension of azcli
so we are going to look at the code in a
moment but before we get there a little
bit of theory
so
classical information theory is actually
relatively simple I mean we can fit it
on one slide everything is a zero or a
one and this is the end of the theory
right now Quantum information theory is
a bit more interesting
so in Quantum information Theory the
basic unit of information is is a
Quantum beat a cubit and mathematically
speaking it is described not by a zero
or a one like a bit but instead it is
mathematically described by a vector a
two-dimensional Vector consisting of two
numbers Alpha and beta complex numbers
by the way
and those two numbers have to fulfill
just one condition which is actually
shown here I can't see so
and this is the so-called normalization
condition so this is read-only
requirement and that already implies
that a qubit can be in one of infinitely
many possible States because we can find
infinitely many alphas and betas to
satisfy this equation
now it gets even more interesting once
we start adding more qubits so once we
add the second qubit well it has its own
Alpha and beta so it is also described
by a two-dimensional vector and now
quantum mechanics tells us that in order
to to provide the full description of
this composite system now consisting of
two qubits we have to calculate the
um we have to calculate the tensor
product between the two vectors and in
linear algebra a tensor product between
two two dimensional vectors produces a
single four-dimensional Vector now if we
add a third qubit then the vector would
become eight dimensional and we can sort
of generalize this by saying that the
quantum State Vector for a program
consisting of n qubits has a
mathematical description that consists
of 2 to the power n Dimensions or in
other words every time we add another
qubit the dimensionality of this Vector
will double and this is precisely why
performing Quantum simulations on the
classical devices and classical
computers is pretty much impossible
because we very quickly run out of
memory
and here is a good example for this so
this is a molecule of penicillin right
it's not a super sophisticated drug
and
basically in order to describe the
quantum State Vector of or in order to
write down a Quantum State Vector of a
molecule of penicillin
we actually need 10 to the power 86 bits
so this is in in order for us to be able
to capture all the all the spin orbitals
of all the atoms involved and so on and
this is a huge number right it is so big
that we estimate that this is more than
the amount of atoms in the entire
universe which we think is about 10 to
the power 80. so in other words if I
wanted to simulate fully the molecule of
penicillin on my laptop or in fact for
that matter on the fastest supercomputer
in the world
I would have to use the entire universe
as my memory now in principle the same
thing can be done on a quantum computer
with 286 logical qubits logical cubes
means error three qubits and the reason
for that is simple 2 to the power 286 is
roughly 10 to the power 86. so a quantum
computer has access to this sort of
vector space that that allows it to
perform this type of simulation
so we know at this stage that the qubit
is much different than a beat but they
have one thing in common
so a bit can only be a zero or a one now
a cube beat can be in one of infinitely
many states we already said that
but
quantum mechanics puts quite a severe
restriction on us namely it only allows
us to distinguish two of those States
from each other at once so effectively
only two of those states are observable
to us and the states that are typically
used are the mathematically simplest
cases where Alpha is one and beta is
zero and vice versa and these vectors
are actually shown here and this symbol
here that we have so this symbol here
and on the other side this is a
so-called cat so cat0 and Cat one this
is a notation from quantum mechanics and
it's just a shorthand way of writing a
vector so that we don't have to write
the full column but instead we can write
the the shorthand symbol
now this also allows us to map a state
of a cube to a classical bit so if we
see a qubit in a state cat 0 we will
treat it as a bit zero and if we see a
cubit in state Cat 1 well then we will
treat it as as beat one and this of
course works in the opposite direction
as well if I want to input a zero into a
quantum computer then I will create a
state cat 0 in a quantum computer and if
I want to input a one I would create a
state cat 1.
the state of a qubit can be visualized
on what is called the block sphere so at
least the mathematics of the cube it can
be visualized on what is called the
block sphere and this is a sphere and we
start at the center and if we draw a
vector to a code encode North Pole this
will be our vector cat0 and the vector
that starts at the center and is drawn
to the South Pole this is the vector cat
one and again these are the only two
states that we can actually observe in a
qubit
but actually any other Vector that we
draw from the center of the sphere to
the surface of the sphere is also a
valid qubit state so what about all
these other states then well it could be
a state like this so there is a red
arrow here
and that state is not a state cut 0 and
it's not a state cat one
but it is actually a linear combination
mathematically speaking of both cat 0
and Cat 1 and this leads us to the most
important equation that we will see
today this is a general equation for a
state of a qubit alpha hat zero plus
beta cat one notice that when Alpha is 1
and beta is zero we simply have a state
cut zero and when beta is one and Alpha
is zero we have a state cat one but if
they are both non-zero then we have a
vector that doesn't point to the North
Pole doesn't point to the South Pole it
might be like this red arrow that we
have on on the slide and this is a
superposition State because in that case
both Alpha and beta are actually
non-zero and this state is there but it
is actually something that we cannot
observe right so we can rely on the fact
that it's there we can try to use it in
some calculations but we will never be
able to see it so we can never ask a
qubit what state you are currently in
and it will say well thanks for asking
I'm in a superposition right what
happens
when you try to observe or measure a
qubit that is in a superposition state
it will actually collapse to either cat0
or Cat 1 and this is the so-called
Quantum State collapse and the outcome
of that is probabilistic and this is why
we say that there is uncertainty that is
building built into the very fabric of
our reality
I'm going to repeat this because it's
really important it is actually a
fundamental Quantum Doctrine and this
applies not to just quantum computers it
really applies to everything in our
world right
that an observation or a measurement of
a given Quantum property does not reveal
a pre-existing value of that property it
is in fact quite the opposite
the outcome of the measurement or an
observation of a Quantum object is
brought into being by the sheer Act of
observation itself
and this has very deep philosophical
consequences of course and you know the
brilliant Austrian physicist Anton
seilinger said the world is not as real
as we think because effectively the the
default state of the world is a
superposition State and only through
observations or through measurements the
quantum objects are forced to collapse
to observable States now this is
something that we will not dive into in
this session but what we can say is that
even though this is probabilistic we can
calculate those probabilities and this
is the best that we can do
and the rules here are super simple
actually the alphas and betas are
actually probability amplitudes in this
case so the probability of collapsing to
cat0 is simply absolute value of alpha
squared and probability of collapsing to
cat1 is absolute beta squared and again
remember when Alpha is 1 and beta is
zero we said we have a state cat zero
but we what we really have is we have a
we have a hundred percent probability of
a collapse to get zero and vice versa
when beta is one and Alpha zero we have
a hundred percent probability of a
collapse to get one but if they are both
non-zero so when we are in a
superposition State there is some
probability of collapsing to cat0 and
some probability of collapsing to get
one and this is also why we had this
normalization conditions uh to begin
with because those numbers squared when
we add them up they have to add up to
one because they represent classical
probabilities
and together this whole thing is called
the born Rule and this was developed by
maxborn
in the second half of the 1920s
and maxborn actually went on to win the
Nobel Prize for that and to this day
this is one of the postulates of quantum
mechanics but the remarkable thing is
that this is not derived from anything
and I don't want to trivialize this but
it was effectively guessed
and it has just always been correct
right
so now at this stage what we can do is
we can sort of summarize what is the
main difference between a classical
program and a Quantum program so a
classical program has some input then it
executes whatever workflow it wants to
execute and it has some output and at
each state it operates on Beats so the
Beats come in then the Beats get
shuffled around and then ultimately the
bits come out
and at any point in this process we can
actually pause the execution of a
program we can look inside the CPU
register like we can unpack everything
everything is fully transparent in fact
everything is deterministic as well
now in a Quantum program it's it's a bit
different because we can also only input
classical bits into a quantum computer
we have to encode them as state cat0 or
cat 1. then the program executes and
when the program executes the qubits can
enter the superposition State they can
become entangled which we'll talk about
in a moment
they can explore this state space that
they have access to so in this case
these are three qubits right so they
would have a 80 Dimensions like eight
dimensional Vector to sort of explore
but it could be a lot more of course
but this is actually not accessible to
us it's a black box like we can think
what is happening in inside there we can
try to nudge it into a certain direction
but it is something that we cannot
observe because as soon as we try to
observe the result of the computation
the quantum States like it's shown here
they would collapse to get 0 or get one
for every single qubit which effectively
means since this is a mapping to
classical bit that classical bits come
out so the major difference is is during
the program execution actually
and and the outcome of course like we
said is probabilistic right so the task
of a Quantum algorithm is to try to
filter those probabilities towards the
correct answers
now
Einstein hated all of this right and
this is the title of the session so he
famously said God does not play dice
you know what Niels Bohr responded when
Einstein said that he said Einstein
don't tell God what to do
foreign
the thing with quantum computers is that
we will not be telling God what to do
but we can actually play God
because we can actually try to organize
the qubits into a real program that does
something and the way we do this is by
building up circuits
and this is sort of conceptually similar
to logical circuits that we can build on
on the CPU or you know with beat logic
at the lowest possible level of
interactional Beats right so this is I
think something that most people have
seen at some point in in the computer
science education and effectively we can
take beats and we can apply logic gates
to them and this way we can build up any
algorithm
now it is somewhat similar in the
quantum world where we have
and we have qubits and we can build up
qubits into circuits and from there we
can actually have uh effectively a
program that executes and the gates The
Logical gates in this case in Quantum
Computing are actually linear operators
from linear algebra and the reason why
they are linear operators is of course
because the state of a qubit is a vector
so how do we act on vectors well we can
act on vectors by multiplying them using
matrices and effectively all those Gates
here so on this diagram here each
horizontal line represents a qubit and
then the symbols here are Gates so each
of those Gates is a matrix so here there
is a matrix that is applied to the
middle qubit then this weird symbol is
actually a two qubit gate so it acts on
qubit number two and three and so on and
effectively as those matrices are
applied to the the the the vector state
of the qubit the vector state would
change and this is how our program
evolves
so what does it mean well here's an
example of such a gate so it's an age
gate one that is used quite often it is
named like this after French
mathematician Jacques adamant
and it has a matrix representation that
looks like that
and the reason why it is useful is it
can take a state cut 0 or cat one so
effectively one of the initial States
because this is how we can encode
information in the first place into a
quantum computer and create what is
called a uniform superposition so we can
go through this calculation and see why
this works so if we apply H to the to
the vector cat0 then of course the
Matrix representation of H is something
that we know already and then the state
cat0 actually has a vector
representation one over zero and if we
calculate this this is what we end up
with this is the vector so Alpha is 1
over square root of two and beta is 1
over square root of two and if we recall
the equation that we saw earlier alpha
cat 0 plus beta Cat 1 so we can rewrite
it this way and this is the ending State
like after this operation so what does
it mean because Alpha and beta are both
non-zero this means we are now in a
superposition and since we can use the
bottom rule to calculate the
probabilities here we can apply the
board rule we can square Alpha and Beta
And what do we end up with one over two
and that means that there is actually a
50 probability of collapsing to get zero
and fifty percent probability of
collapsing to get one so effectively the
our qubit is now in a state where it is
you know effectively a perfect Quantum
cointose in fact it is now a coin toss
that is underpinned by the laws of
nature which is something that you can
never achieve on a classical Hardware
now we are going to continue with this
in a moment but I wanted to take a short
one slide detour into the behavior of
waves so waves and this actually applies
to all the waves so waves on the surface
of water you know sound waves I mean
light behaves like a wave as well
when two waves meet they interfere with
each other and they can interfere either
constructively or they can interfere
destructively and in the first case this
is the first
example or or extreme case where two
waves are identical and they are what we
would say in Phase so they are aligned
perfectly and so when those two waves
meet they would create a bigger wave and
in the second case the waves are
actually shifted by half a wavelength
and so when they meet they would
actually cancel each other out
and why do I bring this up so if we go
back to our our qubit state so we
applied H to it and now we are in a
state that looks like this
if we now observe or measure this qubit
it would produce randomly cat0 or cat
one and we would have our random beat
but what if we don't observe it yet what
if we apply H again what's going to
happen
well we can do the calculation right so
we take H we take our current state and
the Matrix of H is something that we
know and this state Alpha is 1 over
square root of 2 Beta is one over square
root of two so this is a vector we do
this calculation and we end up with one
over zero which is effectively a state
cut 0. so what happened is that the
qubit was forced out of the
superposition and now it's just in a
state cut 0.
so what happened here actually
interference happened
so the
the probability amplitude here and the
probability amplitude here is
effectively described by a wave and so
the the two waves that um represent the
probability of collapsing to cat0 they
get Amplified and they become one so
they go from one over square root of two
to one whereas this probability wave
because of the destructive interference
gets uh reduced or canceled out to zero
and this is how we end up with the state
cat0 at the end and the reason why I
bring this up is that this is one of
those key things that you need to do in
Quantum algorithms you basically want to
amplify the correct results and sort of
cancel out the the incorrect results and
overall the strength of quantum
computers is actually this ability to
compute stuff in the superposition and
be able to take advantage of that
including also constructive and
destructive interference and this is
what we in general would call Quantum
parallelism and the definition of
quantum parallelism
or the way you can think of quantum
parallelism is given a function f of x
instead of evaluating f for different
values of X you can pass a superposition
of all the possible values of X and try
to calculate from there now this is very
subtle actually the whole effect is very
subtle so we should not read too much
into this but this is actually the the
way to begin thinking about this and
this actually leads us to the most basic
logical problem that the quantum
computer can solve
uh in a more efficient fashion than a
classical computer this is a so-called
deutsche's problem
and so you're given a function that
takes in a bit input and produces a bit
output and the task is to determine if
the function is constant or balanced now
because there is just one bit input and
one bit output there are only four
possible cases or permutations right so
let's unpack them so it's either
whatever you input there is always a
zero that comes out which is the first
case this is a constant zero and we have
a constant one so whatever your input 0
comes out so basically the other way we
can we can say that is the function
Returns the same thing for all the
inputs right and in the the other two
cases the function returns different
things for different inputs so we input
0 0 comes out we input one one comes out
and we input 0 1 comes out and we input
one zero comes out and these two
functions at the end they are balanced
so now classically using classical logic
you have to evaluate the function twice
to be able to determine if the function
is constant or balanced here is a
decision tree for that but just using
Common Sense imagine you input 0 into
the function and 0 comes out well you
have no idea if this function is
constant constant zero or is it actually
balanced right so you have to input one
to determine whether the function is
constant or balanced
now remarkably a quantum computer can do
this in a single evaluation of the
function by using a superposition
and so this is the Quantum circuit that
can achieve that and now
in order to unpack this circuit we would
have to actually dive into
quite a bit of linear algebra which is
actually something that I wanted to
avoid in this session so instead what I
will suggest that we do is we have a
look at an analogy so this is the
analogy that I came up with
this is a siblings analogy right just
like as it it is the case with all
analogies we should not push it too far
but it should hopefully illustrate what
a quantum computer can do that the
classical computer can't so imagine we
have two sets of siblings ones that are
identical twins on the left and then we
have regular siblings on the right
we can only ask them one question how
are you doing and they can only answer
good or bad right so the identical twins
will always answer the same thing
right good good or bad bad and the
regular siblings because they would
always fight they always say the
opposite thing
now we have basically now reconstructed
Deutsch's problem using siblings and it
should make it a bit I think more
intuitive to understand what is going on
so now imagine that you are in a dark
room which actually conveniently we are
in a dark room
so this is my dark room now and
imagine that there are two people in
there two siblings you you cannot see
them but you can ask them questions you
can ask how are you doing now
classically speaking you have to ask
them one by one because that is what
regular computer can do it can only
invoke the function you know by passing
in a zero or a one
so a classical computer would ask the
first sibling how are you doing and the
answer might come back and it's good
right
now we do have to ask the second sibling
the answer comes back good and now we
know these are identical twins right it
might have played out differently as
well right so we asked the first one we
hear bad but we still have to ask the
second one now we hear good this means
that these are regular siblings
now here's what the and this is I mean
this gets a bit shaky because it's just
an analogy but here is what a quantum
computer would do a quantum computer can
ask in a superposition so the quantum
computer asks a question and both
siblings get the get get the question so
they both answer
however because of the quantum State
collapse right we cannot observe a
superposition we we can when we try to
observe a qubit there will be a Quantum
State collapse so we can only hear one
answer so we cannot hear both of those
answers that would be too easy
but here's the thing
imagine that these are identical twins
right so they answer the exact same
thing
now the two sound waves representing
their answer
interfere constructively and what we get
is we get a louder answer and from that
we can actually infer that these are
identical twins
and and similarly if these were regular
siblings they would both get the
question they would vote answer but they
now answer different things so their
answers now interfere destructively and
we hear just gibberish in this case and
so from that we can infer that these are
identical as these are regular siblings
this is effectively the gist of it right
so this is the analogy so now going back
to our Quantum circuit this is
effectively what we would reach if we
went through the linear algebra so we
would find out that using our qubit if
the qubit collapses at the end to get
zero it means that the result of an
execution of a function for f of 0 and F
of 1 is actually identical right so
basically in that case the probability
of collapsing to cat0 gets Amplified
whereas if F of 0 and F of 1 return a
different result which means the
function is balanced not constant then
the probability for collapsing to Cat 1
gets Amplified because of the the
interference the constructive
interference and this is effectively the
gist of it again
um
this is quite a subtle thing and it
helps to go through the mathematics but
I hope that the analogy helped so at
this stage what we can now do
is we can have a look at some code
finally
so is this large enough or should I make
it larger
I don't see anybody anyway so I'm not
sure nothing uh
yeah so here's the most basic QR program
that you can have right it is a program
that allocates a single qubit it then
places this qubit in a superposition by
applying the H transformation and then
it performs a measurement so it observes
this qubit and at this point the qubit
will collapse with 50 probability look
at zero or Cat 1 which is effectively
something that we can then map to a
classical zero or classical one so I'm
going to run this
and I'm going to run this oops
I'm going to run this using an
orchestrator that will execute this
program at uh 10 000 times so that we
see a probability distribution this runs
on the local simulator that comes with
the quantum development kit and notice
what happens we get a probability
distribution that we were sort of
expecting right so 50 zeros and fifty
percent ones now we said that if I apply
H twice in a row what we should get is
because of interference we should only
get zeros again and so if this now
executes we should see now that we get
10 000 zeros right
so of course we can build up this
example further
by creating a random number generator
right so in this case what we are doing
we are allocating 16 qubits this is an
array syntax array syntax of Q sharp so
we now have 16 qubits in an array we
will place each of those qubits into a
superposition by applying H to every
single qubit this is a helper operation
in in Q sharp I could have done it in a
loop for example that would have worked
as well of course
and then we have to extract classical
beats out of those qubits so we do this
by measuring the qubit and in this case
the multium operation measures the whole
array
in in fact what it does really it goes
through every single qubit in that array
and measures them individually but again
it's just a convenience in Q sharp to to
be able to operate on an array without
having to Loop through it and we get it
we get results out of this right and
those results are either zeros or one
and they are random and so we can
convert those random bits into an
integer of course
and so I'm going to run this and this
should give us a random unsigned 16-bit
integer and again the randomness here is
underpinned by the laws of nature right
it is not simulated Randomness like it
is the case of classical computers so if
I run this again I should get a
different number unless I'm super lucky
so there you go
so what we can now do is just to see the
probability distribution I'm going to
change this
and I'm going to change this to just two
qubits and I'm going to execute it again
now because I change it now to two
qubits though this is a two-bit integer
now so it's a number between 0 and 3
right 0 1 2 and 3. but the reason why I
wanted to do this is uh just so that we
can see that the probability
distribution and notice that this is
exactly what we were expecting right so
25 cases we get 0 1 2 and 3.
okay so the next thing that we can do is
we can actually submit this to Azure
Quantum to have a look at how it would
feel in Azure Quantum unfortunately
because Azure Quantum is a is a preview
service it is mostly down since
yesterday evening
so we shall we will not be able to do
this I mean we can try so what I'm going
to do is
I'm going to
submit it to
the provider called ionq so I'm going to
show you what this does so here is a
program that I'm trying to submit it's
effectively the same program that we
just saw except it uses four qubits so
it's a four bit random number
and the script that I just executed it's
going to submit it to Azure Quantum to
the inq Area 1 Quantum Processing Unit
which is the newest Quantum processing
unit and also to the imq simulator
so this is now being submitted and we
can we we can see that it was actually
placed in the queue and we get an ID
back
so what I can now do is I can jump over
to Azure quantum
and and let's see what happens in Azure
quantum
now this is something that you can set
up for yourself if you wanted to it is
in public preview so anybody has access
to this
and once you have provisioned another
quantum workspace you should jump over
here to the providers
and and then you can add a provider
right I've already added all of them
and these two and the last one ionq
continue and rigati these are the
vendors that provide Quantum hardware
and normal irrigate is the one that has
been the most stable one but
unfortunately since yesterday it is
actually unavailable now then we have
ionq
and so imq you can see these are the
different targets so this is the old
Quantum processing unit that they have
it's it's not available anymore it was
actually taken out the aria1 is the
newer one that they have but
unfortunately the wait time in the queue
is a week so
so let's meet here next Friday
um the simulator is available though and
then
um a Continuum it has more targets but
the relevant ones are unfortunately
degraded so long story short we can jump
over here to the job management and you
can see the jobs that I have submitted
and so these are the two ones that I
have submitted
and the the quantum processor job is an
unfortunately stuck in waiting and the
simulator one has completed
now I tried the different ones yesterday
and they are all stuck in Waiting State
and and this is unfortunate because for
all the previous days I was actually
checking this every day because I was
worried that it would not work and it
was working every single day so anyway
what we can do however is we can at
least fetch the output of the simulator
in this case
and for that I have a command helper
command and so this is the helper
command and let's see what the simulator
tells us so in this case the simulator
would tell us I mean it should not be a
particularly surprising
uh oops I think I made a mistake here
let's try it one more time
this
and
this one
so the simulator tells us that
I mean this program because it's
generating a 4-bit random integer has 16
possible outcomes and they are all
equally like likely so uh you know from
that perspective it's not a particularly
exciting demo but
um
in a way it is quite cool even though it
is not working at the moment that you
know it is possible to interact with
real Quantum Hardware from your own
laptop I mean in many aspects quantum
computers are some of the most
sophisticated machines that the human
mind has ever built so you know just
being able to interact with them
um in the cloud is is quite cool
now the last thing that I wanted to show
you here is the deutsche's algorithm
and
in this case we have the four functions
constant zero constant one balance same
balance opposite they are implemented
here but as it was the case with the
deutsche's algorithm they are sort of
considered a black box so we should not
even look at them
and basically this is this is the
implementation that was there on the on
the quantum circuit that we had on the
slide
and this algorithm model does it it will
run Deutsch's algorithm for all four
functions right and the first two
functions are the the constant functions
then the two functions are balanced
functions and remember what we said when
the the algorithm produces a zero it
means it has detected a constant
function and if it produces a one it has
detected a balanced function so what we
can now do we can run this and again I'm
going to run this using the orchestrator
the orchestrator will run 10 000 times
and it should produce 10 000 times the
result 0 0 1 1 which is exactly what we
were expecting
so if you'd like to dive deeper into
this I'll have a link to this to all
these demos at the end
so let's go back to the slide the final
thing that I wanted to talk about is
entanglement and in many ways
entanglement it is actually even weirder
than superposition
so how can we create an anglement well
we can do this using the C node gate a
controlled not gate and it has a matrix
representation that is shown here now
you might ask at this point the question
why is this Matrix bigger than the H
Matrix which is actually a very good
question thank you for asking so um
you know it's a really good question so
the the the size of the Matrix of
representing the logic gate in this case
corresponds to the amount of qubits that
it acts upon so the age gate acts on the
single qubit only because the single
qubit state is two-dimensional The
Matrix has to be two by two as well now
the C naught acts on two qubits a state
of two qubits because of the tensor
product is four dimensional and
therefore the Matrix has to be
four-dimensional as well
and what this gate does it treats the
first qubit as a control and the second
qubit is a Target and it will
flip or apply the not logic to the
Target if the control is in a state cat
1. so in other words we can we can we
can draft a a sort of a truth table
so this is our first qubit the second
qubit right control Target and in the
first two cases because the control is
in a state cat 0 well effectively
nothing happens when we apply C naught
that is really no change to our qubits
but in the second of the of the or the
bottom two cases
because the control is in a state Cat 1
the target gets flipped so it gets
flipped from uh cat 0 to cat one and
from cat one to get zero
now you might you might actually object
at this stage and say well there's
nothing Quantum about this right because
we can we can plug in Here regular beats
or or booleans and it would work the
exact same way and that is true however
we can also ask an interesting question
namely what happens when the control is
in a superposition
now we already said that when the qubit
is in a superposition we can consider it
to be in both States cat 0 and Cat 1 at
the same time
but if in the C note gate it is supposed
to flip the target if it is in a state
Cat 1 then
when it is in a superposition of both
cat0 and Cat one would it Flip or would
it not flip the Target and the answer is
both
it would both flip it and not flip it
and effectively we can calculate this
right so we can take two qubits in state
cat zero apply H to the first one this
creates a superposition over the control
and now we apply C naught to both of
them and once we go through the the
calculation this is what we end up with
and this looks very much like a
superposition state that we that we saw
before except it now spans across two
qubits in a way I mean superposition is
sort of contagious it has spilled from
one qubit into the other qubit now
and what this tells us is that when
these qubits are observed
they would both collapse to get zero or
both would collapse to get one because
they are entangled right so for the time
being they both of them are both cad0
rank at one simultaneously but when they
get observed they would both collapse to
get zero and both collapse took at one
with 50 probability there is never going
to be an outcome where one collapses two
cat one and one collapses to get zero
this is entanglement now it doesn't seem
like much but it completely destroys our
understanding of reality
because here's the thing quantum
mechanics also tells us that an
entangled State cannot be decomposed
into a tensor product of the individual
Quantum State now this is a fancy way of
saying that from the perspective of
quantum mechanics the smallest possible
unit of reality now is this entangled
pair of qubits or particles or whatever
you entangle
they do not exist as independent
entities anymore there is no
mathematical description in quantum
mechanics to actually separate them
anymore they have to be considered as
one
but the problem is we can send one of
them over there and we can send the
other over there in principle they could
be at the opposite ends of the universe
and still quantum mechanics will tell us
that they form one thing and we have to
consider them together
now
this is quite interesting because
they are both of them are actually in a
superposition so when we measure them
one of them it would collapse randomly
to cat0 and get one when the second one
is measured they would sort of
synchronize themselves to make sure that
they produce the exact same value
now
Chinese researchers they have a Quantum
satellite in the low orbit and they can
actually create entanglement in the
satellite and they can beam one of the
particles in the entangled pair to a
ground station in China and the other to
a ground station in Europe now what you
can do for example is you can time the
measurement of those particles to the
fraction of a second to ensure that no
influence can propagate between them not
even light has enough time to travel
between them and yet they would always
produce the exact same value
now Einstein hated it right he called it
spooky action at the distance
and
he spent a lot of time trying to prove
that this is incorrect and he had this
idea that you know what there is no
Randomness here at all it is all
predetermined like he basically said
when they get entangled they agree on
what they would collapse to let's say
let's agree to collapse to get zero then
they go their separate ways and then
they collapse to get zero then there is
no mysterious influence or
synchronization happening but he
actually never found a mathematical
solution for this and the reason is
because he was wrong in 1964 at CERN in
Geneva John Bell came up with a
brilliant mathematical proof that showed
that the correlations exhibited by
Quantum objects entangled Quantum
objects are stronger than anything that
you can pre-encode into them and we call
this non-locality and locality means
that effectively in physics locality
means that no influence can propagate
faster than the speed of light
and last year's Nobel Prize in physics
Was Won by another aspect John clauser
and Anton seilinger who over the 1970s
80s and 90s developed a series of
experiments that basically showed that
entanglement is really there and that
John Bell was right and Einstein was
wrong
now we don't really know what
entanglement is like we we have no way
of capturing or even explaining what it
is other than there is this mysterious
link between the two particles but
amazingly enough we can take a
computational advantage of entanglement
in quantum computers
so that's what we can do
so here is a program that actually
creates entanglement and it does exactly
the stuff that we talked talked about
moments ago so it would allocate two
qubits a control qubit and a Target
qubit it then places the control in a
superposition by applying H
transformation to it and then it applies
C note to both of them
and at this Stage Line 12 the qubits are
actually entangled
so what we can then do is we can measure
them we can measure them in any order
that we want and both would collapse to
get 0 or both would collapse to get one
but there would be no other possible
outcome so let's try to run this again
this will run in a in a in an
orchestration of 10 000 executions and
notice in half of the cases we get two
zeros and in half of the cases we get
two ones
now we can extend this further by
building a random number generator that
is now entangled
so in this case we are going to allocate
eight qubits so and we will call them
Alice then we will allocate another set
another array of eight cubits and we
call them Bob
and we shall entangle those two qubit
arrays and this is using a helper
operation from Q sharp repair entangled
state but really internally it actually
does a loop and the H and the C not all
the stuff that we discussed so far and
effectively we now have two arrays that
are entangled so elements at index zero
are and fungus together elements at
index one are entangled together and so
on so we have eight pairs of entangled
qubits now here at line 23 I mean if you
squint your eyes you can you can imagine
that Alice takes her qubits and goes one
way and Bob takes these cubes and goes
the other way in fact we could send
those cubes maybe using a Quantum
communication Network I mean in
principle one of them could fly to a
different galaxy doesn't matter
what matters is that at some point they
can measure their qubits and at that
point they would really receive a random
number because the qubit will collapse
to either random cat zeros or or their
set of qubits will corrupt to a random
set of cat0s and Cat ones so effectively
if they get a random set of beats
but they can be sure that their
counterpart wherever the counterpart is
will receive the exact same random
numbers upon measurement as well and so
basically this program runs in a loop of
100 executions
and keeps track of all the numbers and
and make sure that they are all the same
and this is really the case right so in
100 out of 100 cases the measurement is
the same
and what is the consequence of this
so let's say Alice is there and Bob is
there and they have now the same random
number well a random number a random set
of Beats is nothing more than
um for example an encryption key so they
can use this to engage now in a
symmetric encryption
and here's the thing though the
difficult thing in symmetric encryption
is actually the key distribution now in
this case the key was effectively
distributed through entanglement right
so one of them had their own set of
cubies the other had their own set of
Cubes they didn't really have any value
until they were measured when they got
measured they acquired the value which
was somehow synchronized to their
counterpart now imagine that you are an
attacker and you'd like to attack this
and steal the key well there's nothing
for you to attack because no information
traverses the space and time between
Alice and Bob
and when R2 record came up with this
protocol in 1991 in his PhD thesis
actually he called it quantum key
distribution without an Associated
element of reality and if you think
about this this is just so mind-boggling
and this is not science fiction right
like it just describes technology that
we are able to already use today
okay I think at this point
we have done everything thank you so
much
um if you would like to
if you'd like to see those slides that
they are online the demos are also
online
if you happen to open this slides you
can click here to go to a shop and buy
my book there's actually a promo right
now you can get it for 16 Euro and uh
and I think that's it now I used up
almost all of the time so and also
there's a lunch break so my proposal is
that we don't do any questions but if
you'd like to talk about anything that
we covered here just just come up
afterwards to me grab me and I'd be
happy to to talk about anything I also
have one other thing I wanted to say I
have one copy of my book that I'd like
to give away so just the first person
that comes up and says they want a book
you can have it thank you so much again
for coming I really really appreciate it
thank you
[Applause]